[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi 25
janvier ils ne sont pas encore diplômé
mais déjà tourné vers l'avenir des
étudiants de l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines organisé un
forum des métiers
l'occasion pour eux de rencontrer leurs
futurs leur éventuel futur employeur d
éventuels employeurs régnait aussi à
versailles pour la cérémonie des voeux
du medef 78 notre journaliste haussmann
vendeurs d viendra nous dire quels sont
les projets des chefs d'entreprise pour
cette année dans ce journal également
suite de notre dossier métier méconnu
avec un zoom ce soir sur les luthiers
entre passion pour la musique et le bois
mais on ouvre ce journal avec de la
politique et l annonce du maire de
versailles françois de mazières le
député maire divers droite a déclaré
qu'il ne briguerait pas un nouveau
mandat de député en juin prochain une
annonce dans le cadre de la nouvelle loi
sur le cumul des mandats qui entrera en
vigueur le 31 mars dans une interview au
journal le parisien françois de mazières
a également indiqué qu'il souhaitait
voir son adjoint chargé de la jeunesse
et l'enseignement supérieur
françois-xavier bel ami à lui succéder
nous vous en parlions déjà hier le musée
de la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
a rouvert ses portes cet après midi
après un déménagement et 18 mois de
travaux elle les espaces ont été
agrandis ils sont également plus
lumineux écoutez à ce propos la réaction
des premiers visiteurs au micro de
michael et demi d'euros je suis
passionné des villes nouvelles et
aujourd'hui pour moi la réouverture de
ce musée c'est
c'est quelque chose de ces quelque chose
d'important va pour le territoire et je
crois qu'on devrait plus marqué cette
histoire de notre territoire qu'on
habite je trouve ça sympa quand même et
puis j'ai une copine qui travaillent ici
donc elle m'a conseillé d'aller voir
ahmadi cité plutôt pas mal du coucher
allez voir vous aimez exposé ans quand
j'étais au lycée au collège et donc
c'est important de le voir justement
cette nouveauté c'est une promenade et
en même temps ben je vais voir de
quelque chose que je n'ai jamais vu mon
petit-fils m'emmène et c'est une
surprise
après ses études vers quel métier
s'orienter dans quel secteur voilà des
questions que se posent tous les ans les
étudiants à saint quentin en yvelines
une partie de la réponse se trouvait
hier à la maison de l'étudiant à forum
des métiers étaient organisées par les
intéressés eux-mêmes un moyen de créer
du lien entre les élèves de l'ue vs cul
et les entreprises
reportage de camille lambert ce sera
peut-être leur futur employeur ces
étudiants de l'université de versailles
saint quentin sont venus se renseigner
sur cette entreprise
karl est en master 1 management elle
cherche à travailler dans l'événementiel
et les relations clients
ça avait l'air très sympa et font des
stages justement dans beaucoup de
domaines différents
donc j'ai des saints c'est vais voir ce
que ça peut donner et puis nous ont
donné également leurs coordonnées
sur linkedin et sites internet organisé
par cinq étudiants de l'ue vs cul dans
le cadre de leur formation ce forum des
métiers se veut être un lieu de
rencontre entre élèves et professionnels
un moyen d'y voir plus clair après le
diplôme
au total sept entreprises ont joué le
jeu alors nos intervenants de plusieurs
entreprises qu'on à l'entreprise thalès
on a le groupe sort talentsoft on a
aussi la fondation agir contre
l'exclusion la face des yvelines donc
vraiment c'est très diverses
la plupart sont d'anciens étudiants m et
c'est donc notre formation est donc ça
permet de nous étions des mains pour se
projeter
qu'est ce qu'ils vont devenir qu'est ce
qu'ils vont être plus tard beaucoup pour
des z pour des trous et des stages où
trouver de l'alternance c'est pour ça
qu'on a des personnes ici qui ont
proposé des offres de stages l'idée
c'est qu'on puisse leur donner un peu de
visibilité sur la praye diplômés voire
qu'elles sont là panel de jobs qui
peuvent s'offrir à eux comme par exemple
la partie projet chez talentsoft nous ce
qui nous intéresse en tant qu'entreprise
entre entreprises c'est de pouvoir venir
récupérer un peu de de feedback de la
part de l'étudiant voir un peu comment
se passe leur faim de diplômes détecter
de nouveaux talents également et puis
pour eux c'est effectivement bénéficier
des premiers contacts dans la matinée
une soixantaine de curieux a pu échanger
avec les intervenants
ce forum des métiers était le premier de
cette ampleur un événement qui devrait
être pérennisé sous cette forme dans le
reste de l'actualité locale et non sans
lien les chiffres du chômage ils sont
mauvais dans les yvelines pour le mois
de décembre 2016 le nombre d'inscrits en
catégorie à c'est à dire sans aucune
activité a augmenté de 1,1 pour cent par
rapport à novembre pour s'établir à 64
mille huit cent vingt personnes
sur un an la hausse est moins flagrante
+0 5% de chômeurs sans aucune activité
on reste dans le monde de l'entreprise
et l'emploi bertrand de créer président
du medef yvelines présenté ses voeux le
17 janvier à l'hôtel de france à
versailles la cérémonie qui s'est
déroulée en présence de nombreux chefs
d'entreprises et d'élus a permis de
dresser un bilan de l'année 2016 et les
perspectives pour la nouvelle année 2010
est haussmann vendeurs d vous étiez sur
place
[Musique]
bertrand de créer l'année 2016 a été une
année difficile pour les entreprises
elles ont dû batailler notamment avec
les partenaires sociaux à cause de la
loi elle connerie et puis en 2017
il souhaite concentrer ses efforts sur
la formation écoutez nous il est vrai
problème j'en ai parlé aussi sont des
problèmes de la formation de 2
un citoyen aujourd'hui si je le fais
l'apprentissage parce que je crois que
c'est une voie qui aujourd'hui une voie
d'excellence
il faut redonner corps à des métiers
qu'on a peut être abandonné mais mais
le quasi plein emploi pour tous et moi
c'est possible c'est électorale de 2010
est bertrand de créer l'a dit durant son
discours
le medef n'a pas vocation à soutenir des
partis politiques est content quand même
avoir du poids sur les prochaines
échéances
on aura des points et je le dis dans
discours
important des points clés
baisse des charges pour regagner des
marges de l'agilité l'investissement
un droit du travail
assouplies
une fiscalité assouplies et une
formation aussi et nous rencontrerons
pas percement avec des entrepreneurs
tous les candidats
alex aux législatives nous les
rencontrerons
et nous discuterons avec eux pour leur
faire part de ce que nous voulons et ce
que nous croyons et cette volonté de
mettre le point sur la formation est
importante pour le président
d'initiatives saint quentin en yvelines
yves fouchet c'est un point important
pour aider les jeunes à la recherche
d'un emploi on parle du chômage et
notamment de celui des jeunes
la vérité c'est que la majorité des
jeunes chômeurs sont des chômeurs des
jeunes qui n'ont pas de formation
donc il est déterminant pour eux d'abord
parce que s'ils veulent trouver un job
de plus en plus de travaux nécessitent
un minimum de formation donc pour eux
d'abord et pour les entreprises aussi
parce que bon des métiers historiquement
dans la mécanique et autres ont disparu
et ne reviendront pas mais donc il faut
un minimum de formation
merci haussmann pour toutes ces
précisions
un peu de douceur à présent dimanche
dernier l'association voisins adultes
euros les organiser le 3e salon du
bien-être à la maison des associations
de voisins-le-bretonneux lors de
l'événement plus de 200 personnes ont pu
découvrir la géobiologie le massage sur
chaise ou encore le nettoyage de karma
avec un objectif atteindre le bien-être
je pense que la place du bien-être
prendre justement de plus en plus de
place parce que vu la conjoncture on
épisode de plus en plus stressé il est
important pour être bien quand même de
s'occuper un petit peu de soi faire la
démarche pour trouver quel une méthode
qui nous conviennent et pour cela le
salon à cet objectif là de faire
découvrir différentes méthodes et a
pressé les personnes qui peuvent choisir
ce qui pourrait leur faire du bien du
sport pour la bonne cause le plaisir
handball a organisé samedi dernier un
tournoi de hand féminin à but caritatif
objectif soutenir l'association un kazoo
paix à une structure qui lutte contre le
cancer du sang au total huit équipes ont
participé à ce rendez vous pour récolter
des fonds l'intégralité des bénéfices va
permettre à cazaux pea de participer au
grand raid ultramarins du morbihan l'été
prochain on écoute lune
organisatrice du tournoi magali tout 1
au micro de nicolas d'andry il y avait
une participation une adhésion de 50
euros par par équipes et tous les
bénéfices de la journée reviennent à
l'association cassiopea déjà c'était 50
euros l'adhésion par équipes y avait
huit équipes donc on est déjà à 400
euros
et derrière les bénéfices de la buvette
on pense être entre 200 et 300 euros de
bénéfices
on referme ce journal avec notre dossier
de la semaine les profession méconnue on
vous présente ce soir l'activité d'un
luthier gens de manger est un retraité
passionné qui continue à fabriquer des
instruments à coignières découverte de
l'activité et de l'homme aussi avec
nicolas landry et camille lambert
c'est un instrument de musique créé en
italie au xvième siècle le théorbe gens
de manger à fabriquer celui-ci de ses
propres mains avec 14 corde pour un prix
de vente autour des 2500 euros ceci est
un terme avec puis corps sur le manche
et si quand sur l'extérieur qui sont les
coeurs passe le manche est notamment
beaucoup plus lent que sur un but
classique
c'est la forme d'un luth bien sûr on
peut pas dire le contraire mais il ya
une prolongation au niveau 2 au niveau
de la tête
je vous ai mis combien de temps son
activité créée redonner vie aux
instruments de musique à cordes violon
guitare ou contrebasse un métier entre
art et artisanat apparu au tout début du
xvième siècle cette passion jeandemange
elle a débuté en 1973 avec sa boutique à
versailles
si je marchais l'ébéniste de
l'ébénisterie je me dire qu'en vertu du
traité vraiment bon je fais un truc qui
m'a catalan 13 faisait des guitares le
luthier restaure façonnent les voûtes et
pose les vernis de résine un
savoir-faire exigeant qui nécessite
aussi bien une solide connaissance des
différents matériaux qu une grande
culture technique et historique et
surtout beaucoup de persévérance
quand on enseigne un truc comme ça
cd suite après après l'enseignement que
la personne a
le métier en main deux tours de trouver
des possibilités de s'installer cetera
et cetera
parce que
heureusement le métier de sa large de
moins bien la lutherie c'est un métier
il faut être sur le tas pour pouvoir les
avoir à le connaître on n'apprend pas un
métier comme ça en 50 ans présents
pendant dix ans
il faut 20 ans ou 30 ans pour avoir ce
match depuis qu'il est à la retraite
jean de manger vite à coignières est à
74 ans il ne compte pas abandonner sa
vocation
il faut avoir l'oreille musicale et
c'est pas forcément il nécessite le
principal site a accordé un soin si
longtemps que j'ai ma tête et mes doigts
le métier mon métier c'est ma vie
selon un recensement plus de 400 luthier
était en exercice en 2009
un amour du bois et de la musique qui
traverse les siècles
tout comme ces instruments fin de ce 7 8
le journal ont rendez vous demain jeudi
aux horaires habituels pour une nouvelle
édition d'ici là tous nous retrouver
tous nos reportages sont à retrouver en
replay sur tv fil 78 points comme ou
l'application tv fils bonne soirée à
tous
[Musique]